when you dream of sort of releasing
music and getting fans is you don't know
how well you're going to do with fame
how do you think you're doing
I have a lot of famous friends and stuff
so I kind of see how they are and I
think I'm at a really good point you
know I think a lot of cool people know
me and a lot of people like my music
just appreciative and so excited that
everybody I mean the people that do hear
my music liked it and they're supportive
so that's amazing
[Music]
who do you know that does it right like
who do you look at and say you know Eve
just for you like God you know they do
it right I've really really looked up
the childís bunker he's just a great
family man and so positive always
working and like you know it's been a
pleasure to kind of have him be like a
mentor to me and like a brother to watch
how he works and just navigates and
everything he's done it and then even
you know bringing up and helping younger
artists like me and any other people I
think I think I really think he does it
right and I wanna be like it when I grow
up the 22 year old tells us that despite
the pandemic he is still planning on
releasing an album later this year which
will include his brand-new single if I
want to to release a project to keep
releasing music in the quarantine be
because it's not all about performing
for me I think that the music could
really sit well with people even if they
are locked in their house me personally
I'm excited to release music and at a
time like this